David is in Washington DC welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show David how can we help
hi Dave pleasure to talk to you you too
sir okay so I wanted to ask you so I'm a
single dad I'm going to be debt-free at
the end of this month of all my
commercial debts except my mortgage
mm-hmm so I was wondering I was talking
to my parents and they would be okay
with me moving in for a couple years
with them to help pay down my mortgage
while I rent my condo out so that I can
move on to a bigger home what do you
what do you just say about that how old
are you I'm uh
I turned 239 tomorrow how many children
do are you raising so I've got a little
boy and a little girl he's there six
seven and four okay sure are you
divorced or what yes okay all right and
you got full custody it's 50/50 okay all
right cool and what's your household
income sure I gotta increase this year
so making $80,000 and top of bonuses hmm
I've also got a long term investment we
get given you know stock options but
they don't invest for every frontal
three years what's your condo worth
right now I'm finding a little bit above
water it's one hundred and forty seven
thousand and what do you owe on it 147
yeah 147 right now I'm just paying
$1,100 a month for it okay we have
inexpensive housing as opposed to your
income especially for Washington DC and
it's going up in value you've got a good
safe place to live and have kids raise
kids you're 39 years old you make 80
thousand if the way I answer questions
on this show is what would I do if I
were in your shoes and the thing I
always want folks to remember is
personal finance
it's not just math it's life I got
personal in it
okay and so you kind of have to think
about what you would do maybe more than
what Dave would do in this situation I
can tell you just the way I'm wired
the chances of me moving back home at 39
years old
short of some kind of major medical
problem is zero
okay the that would affect my
self-confidence and my dignity in a way
that I couldn't handle now maybe you can
and I'm not saying you're bad if you can
okay but III don't think you've got a
bad situation here right and the only
reason the only reason to do this
mathematically would be to increase the
velocity of which you're able to build
some wealth that's the only reason to do
it but you have a good job you've got
inexpensive housing you're stable you're
out of debt other than the house you're
doing good everything's heading in the
right way you know I I couldn't do it I
couldn't avoid it and I and I think
you're gonna lose something here that
the math is not going to reveal and and
I just it's my opinion and of course you
called for my opinion and I'm an expert
on my opinion so but um you know the
that's kind of the way
in in a different scenario I run into
the same thing even with like a 23 year
old which is a different scenario but my
kids are grown adults and two of them
married the third and getting ready to
get married and so but they after
college you know they might come back
home for a little bit to kind of get
settled and get the apartment lined up
and get some roommates lined up and it
might be a few months but something
happened with my kids that was
observable when they were 100% off my
payroll in the sense that they were they
had to pay their light bill or their
light went off they had to go to the
grocery store or there was no groceries
you know and they had to deal with
roommate scenarios and they had to deal
with you know getting the grass cut or
whatever was involved right of being on
their own but theirs
something that happens when you put a
physical space around you that declares
you to be an adult and is that does that
mean you can't go back home sometimes
yeah sometimes it's a good thing if one
of my kids was hurt or you know had some
kind of finesse or some kind of a major
medical issue and they you know move in
my wife take care of one of them for a
little while absolutely we would do that
but we're gonna be a safety net at the
most but not a hammock and I don't think
you need a safety net here
mathematically you don't and so is it
worth it to the for the change in your
emotional makeup the the regression back
towards childhood moved back in your
chilled I mean it's weird to go back to
my wife's house that she grew up in were
men married 37 years and sleep in the
bed that she slept in when she was a
little girl that's still weird you know
that's just weird
I don't if that doesn't weird some of
you out you're weird I mean that's just
you know it's kind of strange and to do
you know you that's the kind of stuff
I'm talking about here and so but could
we go move in with her dad he's
80-something years old if we couldn't
eat and yeah we could and we would
before we would be homeless or before we
would be starving to death literally and
he would have us he's a good man you
know but I can't tell you man my last
choice there's nothing no reflection on
him it'd just be my last choice so
that's my answer you know you you can do
with it what you want and I'm not gonna
be mad at you we'll still be friends
either way okay I'm not saying you're
stupid or you're bad or you're weak or
anything like that I'm just saying this
is how I view it thanks for the call